what comes to your mind when you hear
the word radioactive well for me it was
this danger right but in this video
we're going to try to understand what
exactly is radioactive or what does it
mean and why is it so dangerous and how
can the same thing be also useful to us
that's what we'll explore so let's begin
to explore what radioactivity is let's
start with something that we familiar
with chemical processes chemical
reactions now you don't have to worry
about this specific chemical reaction
but the thing to focus on is that in
every chemical reaction you find that
the number of elements on the right hand
side is exactly the same as the number
of elements on the left for example you
have four oxygen atoms on the left you
find four oxygen atoms on the right you
have one carbon atoms on the right you
have one carbon atom on the left this
means that you will never be able to get
new elements in your products the
elements on the product side will always
be the same as the elements on the
reactant side but in contrast in
radioactive processes you get new
elements what how you see in chemical
reactions the reason you don't get new
elements is because it's all about
electrons going from one atom to another
and now if you take something like say
carbon and you remove electron from it
or you add electron from it to it or you
share electrons whatever you do carbon
stays carbon electrons do not Define the
identity of an element so now that
brings us to the question then what does
what makes carbon carbon what makes
oxygen oxygen well to answer that
question we need to dig deeper I mean
literally if you were to look in inside
say a carbon atom you probably find
electron zooming around but if you zoom
in to the center you would get the
nucleus of the carbon and you probably
already know the nucleus of an atom
contains protons which are positively
charged particles and neutrons which are
neutral particles now guess what turns
out the identity of an element is
defined by the number of protons so for
example anything that has six protons is
carbon carbon is carbon because it has
six protons similarly anything that has
seven protons would be nitrogen and so
on and so forth It's the number of
protons that decide the identity but you
may ask well what about the number of
neutrons ah the number of neutrons don't
matter actually so for example you can
have carbon which has six neutrons or
you can have carbon which has eight
neutrons you have different nuclei of
carbon available and by the way such
nuclei which have the same same number
of protons which mean the same elements
but different number of neutrons we give
them a name we call them Isotopes and so
in order to be able to differentiate
them we have a notation so the notation
we use for representing nuclei is we
write the C and then we write the number
of protons over here down and then on
the top left we write the total number
of particles not the number of neutrons
so it's 6 + 6 12 so this is how we
represent this nuclei nucleus sorry
similarly how would we represent this
nucleus well we'll represent as C 6 it
has to be six if it wasn't six it
wouldn't be carbon and then on the top
left you would write 6 + 8 we would
represent this as 14 so we would call
this the carbon 12 isotope and we would
call this the carbon 14 isotope and so
you can see it's this number the total
number of particles that differentiate
the Isotopes we give a name to that
number we call it the mass
number because that number represents
the mass in the sense you know here you
have 14 particles so this nucleus will
have more mass compared to this nucleus
which has only 12 particles right and so
when it comes to nuclei the mass number
matters because you you care about both
protons and neutrons but when it comes
to chemical reactions you don't care
about the number of neutrons you only
talk about carbon because they both have
the same chemical properties but not the
same nuclear properties now you might
say mes all of this is great but what
exactly is radioactivity and how does it
create new elements and why is it so
dangerous well in short turns out that
certain nuclei can be very unstable and
for such cases for such nuclei they just
automatically we just spontaneously spit
out some particles and in doing so the
number of protons in them changes as a
result the element changes and that's
how you get new elements that process is
what we call radioactivity now I know
there's a lot to unpack and we'll do
this now so the first question you might
have is what do you mean by nucleus
being unstable now it's not really un
straightforward to understand the
stability of a nucleus but to gain some
intuition think about very heavy nuclei
if you have a very heavy nucleus you can
kind of think understand that there has
a lot of protons and all the protons
want to go away from each other because
they have all positive charges that
makes it so hard to keep the nucleus
together so you can kind of see that
very heavy nuclei tend to be unstable
but what is not so intuitive is is that
light nuclear can also be unstable for
example c14 is an unstable nucleus
versus C12 is stable now you may be
wondering well how can it be they both
have the same number of protons Well
turns out that stability also depends
upon the ratio of the number of protons
and the number of neutrons certain
ratios are more stable compared to the
others and like I said it's not very
straightforward it's not very intuitive
and so we'll not have to remember which
nuclear are stable or which nuclear not
but the bottom line is there are certain
nuclei that are unstable they can be
heavy or they can be light now let's see
what happens to these unstable nuclei so
let's take an example if you take carbon
14 turns out that because it's unstable
it spits out something called the beta
particle and in the result changes to
nitrogen 14 now I know you might be
having a lot of questions like how does
that happen what exactly is a beta
particle and how did the number of
protons increase from 6 to 7 how did
that happen we'll get into all of this
in the future videos in fact this is
called the beta DK that something called
as Alpha DK and Gamma DK but we'll get
into all the fun stuff later on but the
point to see over here is look at what
happened we started with an unstable
parent nucleus that's what we call them
the Paran nucleus which is unstable it's
spontaneously meaning without us having
to do anything to it it just happened
all by itself because it's unstable
spontaneously changed into a more stable
nucleus which we call the do water
nucleus okay and in doing so what has it
done it has spit out some high energy
particle in fact that's how you become
stable right like you let go of some you
release some energy and guess what it's
this high energy particle that's what
makes radioactivity so dangerous now you
might say mahes what do you mean by high
energy like a moving pingpong wall would
literally have billions of more Jewels
energy right so what do you mean by high
energy well you're right but unlike a
pingpong ball these particles can
actually enter into your cells atoms and
knock off electrons destroying bonds
which could damage the cells which could
mutate your DNA that's what makes them
so dangerous so when I say high energy
particles um what we mean over here is
these are ionizing particles we call
them ionizing radiation ionizing means
they have the ability to knock off
electrons but here's the thing the same
thing can be useful for us for example
we can Target these at cancer cells and
try and Destroy them that's what
radiation therapy is all about so if you
understand radioactivity we can control
it and we can use it for some amazing
applications anyways that's it for this
video so in short what is radioactivity
or what is radioactive decay it's a
process in which you have an unstable
nucleus that spontaneously changes to a
new more stable nucleus and in doing so
it releases high energy ioniz
radiation